so for this week's video on comic book
concepts and because so many people had
asked for it what I want to do here is
have a discussion on unstoppable
Colossus now because this involves
Colossus gaining the power of the
juggernaut I want to begin by providing
some information on the history of the
juggernauts power how it relates to the
entity known as Syd Iraq and the events
that led into Colossus gaining the power
for himself
so looking at a new Excalibur issue
number 14 from 2007 what Marvel tells us
is that during the early days of human
history said Iraq existed as an entity
but was viewed as a god and worshiped by
differing human tribes now a distinction
to make here is that this time period is
around 1000 years prior to the current
day in Marvel Comics what this means is
that we're mutants were just beginning
to emerge the Inhumans had already been
created and beings like apocalypse are
rolling around this period in human
history represents the time when
humanity still believed in deities who
had some influence on the planet Earth
however for reasons that were never
explained by Marvel or within the comics
sit Iraq was banished from the earthly
plane to a pocket dimension called the
crimson cosmos now from here in Iron Man
vol 3 issue number 22 what we're told is
that during this period following center
acts banishment he along with several
other entities came together forming a
group called the octet since designed to
be a contest to determine which of the
group was the most powerful in order to
determine a winner each member of the
act essence created an artifact that
would be stored on earth and when the
artifact was touched by the hands of a
human a spell would be triggered
resulting in others being drawn to the
remaining artifacts with each being
taken and allowing for the members of
the audience to engage in a battle with
one another using their avatars now the
issue that we face here is that Marvel
does not tell us why some humans are
drawn to the temple and others aren't
instead Marvel simply just says that
once the artifact is touched the spell
begins now the start of this ritual came
with x-men issue number 12 and the
backstory of Cain Marko and Charles
Xavier as it was written by Stanley and
drawn by Jack Kirby coinciding with the
juggernauts first appearance while it's
only in a short flashback model
establishes that during their time
serving in the Korean War Xavier and
Marko had discovered a temple located in
Asia which had been made to honor Sid
Iraq investigating the ruins and
discovering the Crimson gem hidden
within where Xavier had warned Cain not
to touch it
Cain ignored this warning and after
picking it up recited the now famous
words whosoever touches this Jim shall
possess the power of the crimson bands
of cyttorak henceforth you who read
these words shall become forevermore a
human juggernaut now focusing on the
juggernauts abilities while possessing
the crimson gem of cyttorak
Cain Marko is essentially the
representation of Sid Iraq on earth and
is effectively
Mortal in addition to this we're
different writers have depicted at
different ways the juggernauts strength
largely ranges from being on par with
the Incredible Hulk and his base form to
being a limitless furthermore because
jaggernots the durability is virtually
unrivaled and that he was able to
withstand a blow from Thor's hammer
without any effect his hammer protection
from telepathic attacks he's
invulnerable to diseases possesses a
healing factor has the ability to
generate a force field around himself
and once he starts moving in any
direction under normal circumstances
it's impossible for anyone to stop him
now the reason why I say under normal
circumstances is because there have been
instances where an earthbound being has
been capable of knocking the juggernaut
out stopping his movement or outright
overpowering him this first instance
happened during the onslaught saga to
sidetrack for a second following the
events of fatal attractions which focus
on magneto and his acolytes launching an
attack against the x-men when magneto
pulled the adamantium out of Wolverines
body
Xavier shut Magneto's mind down
believing that he was beyond redemption
following this because Xavier had
suppressed his frustration with
humanity's refusal to coexist with
mutants these themes came together with
uncanny x-men issue number 322 while the
conflict happened off panel and we
weren't shown what took place this story
did provide us with the juggernaut
simply landing in Hoboken New Jersey
completely knocked out while he did wake
up and battle the x-men following his
conclusion juggernaut revealed that not
only had even stopped by onslaught but
during their battle he'd been knocked
across the country a feat that was
previously believed to be unachievable
however the most notable instance of
juggernaut being stopped in his tracks
came during the events of the Incredible
Hulk issue number 456 centering on
apocalypse capturing banner in order to
turn him into the horseman war after
being successful Hulk emerged similar to
his world war hulk appearance and that
he possessed some personal armor and
weaponry now where a lot of this was
designed to add a more intimidating
appearance the benefit of apocalypses
modifications came and that Hulk did not
have to rely on anger to increase his
strength speed and durability instead
his speed and durability were enhanced
to the same levels as juggernaut and he
was able to increase his strength to
match an overpower whoever he was
fighting at the time furthermore because
the story focused on hoax friends
attempting to bring him out from under
apocalypses control they had contacted
the juggernaut for the purpose of
attempting to overcome the Hulk
however during the battle banner was
able to overcome the juggernaut using
his strength enhancements by stopping
him in his tracks and knocking him
across the Sahara Desert and Indic hero
now to continue this trend to Colossus
gaining the power of the juggernaut
while they have had several battles over
the course of the respective histories I
want to actually shift our focus away
from K Marco and to Colossus himself to
sidetrack for a second this bit of
information actually comes out of the
2011 story fear itself written by Matt
Fraction with contributions from Stuart
Immonen Scott Eaton and Steve McNiven
fear itself centered on Marvel superhero
community battling an entity known as
the serpent which claimed to be the
previous ruler of Asgard prior to being
defeated by Odin providing a hammer
called skatey which was similar to
Thor's hammer Mjolnir in that only those
found worthy by the serpent could lift
it once it was picked up by red skulls
daughter she became The Herald of the
serpent after which she released it from
its underwater prison leading to seven
more hammers falling to earth each one
being picked up by a different character
from Marvel Comics who was transformed
into one of the generals of the serpent
regarding the juggernaut after picking
up one of the seven hammers he was
transformed into Kurth the breaker of
stone because the 2008 story manifest
destiny focused on the city of San
Francisco rejecting the civil war
initiative and providing a safe haven to
the x-men after becoming courage Jenner
not launched an attack on the x-men
space of operations in Utopia a small
island off the coast of San Francisco
proper the seeking to defeat came by
usurping his power
Colossus Kitty Pryde and Illyana
Rasputin traveled to the crimson cosmos
to speak with Syd Iraq arguing the
juggernaut had betrayed Syd Iraq by
taking up allegiance with the serpent
while continuing to wield the power of
the juggernaut Colossus Ileana and Kitty
Pryde offered an alternative
strip Cain of the juggernauts power and
provided to Ileana who in turn would
defeat Cain in the name of serac now
where the intention was to have Ileana
become juggernaut instead of letting
this happen
Colossus took her place seized the gym
for himself
and was transformed into the unstoppable
Colossus now in this moment what Marvel
had done was essentially written
themselves into a corner what I mean
here is that for those of you who have
not seen my video on Colossus which
you'll find in the description his
mutation of organic metal skin allows
for resistance to all modern
spins up to and including nuclear
explosions extreme temperatures of hot
and cold most magical attacks and
possesses superhuman strength speed and
durability however after being provided
the powers of the juggernaut these
abilities were enhanced and Colossus was
given new powers making him quite
possibly one of the most powerful
mutants on the planet the reason why is
because the helmet of the juggernaut
serves to protect from telepathic
attacks and the gem of cyttorak provides
all the same powers at the juggernaut
meaning that during this time Colossus
was immune to the effects of magic
telepathy telekinesis conventional
weapons planet shattering explosions and
diseases he also had no need for oxygen
food or water and once he began moving
in any direction
he couldn't be stopped unless he stopped
himself and the only earthbound
individuals capable of overcoming him
were those who could manipulate metal
and people who could warp reality in
addition to this because Colossus was
empowered by the gym these bearing
abilities also came with a desire to
carry out acts of destruction and chaos
in the name of Sid Iraq
now what Colossus was able to combat
these urges for time the issue Marvel
faced was this what do you do with a
character that's so powerful but they
can only be challenged by individuals of
the highest order and how can you write
their stories in a manner that makes
them interesting in truth this wasn't
largely possible at the time and that
much like Franklin Richards any foe the
x-men encountered barring cosmic
entities could have easily been
challenged and defeated by Colossus and
so following the conclusion of fear
itself
and going into uncanny x-men vol 2
underwriter Karen Gillan emphasis was
placed on keeping Colossus as a
background character at the first art
focused on sinister facing off against
the x-men with Colossus essentially
standing around and doing no real
fighting recognizing the issue that came
with this kind of situation almost
immediately over the course of the next
several issues Kieron Gillen said about
returning Colossus to his status quo
beginning with uncanny x-men vol 2 issue
number 5 Kirin introduced tabula rasa a
kind of sphere in Montana that used to
be home to 5000 humans but was replaced
with a temporal anomaly that isolated
the interior from the rest of the world
while the goal of the x-men was to
investigate what caused a situation to
unfold
Ilyana was taken underground by a group
of monsters now our Colossus went into
the tunnels to save Ilyana and most
the events took place off panel after
she had come to the cave was filled with
body parts and colossus - transformed
into a monster now the reason why Karen
included this was to both go towards the
reason for Colossus looking to cast off
the juggernauts power but also establish
that as long as he gives in to the power
of the gym and succumbs to his darker
side his physical form will come to
reflect the essence of what it means to
be a harbinger of CID Iraq and so where
Eliana was able to restore colossus to
his normal juggernaut form by helping
him regain his mind
Colossus eventually had himself locked
up due to the power he possess and his
inability to control it now because this
served the purpose of removing him from
the equation
Marvel didn't return Colossus to the
landscape as an active member of the
x-men team until the Avengers vs. x-men
storyline during this time and with the
Phoenix force imbuing Scott Summers Emma
Frost Illyana Rasputin neighboring
Colossus with his power minor curing
Gillen set in motion the events that
would see Colossus lose his juggernaut
essence returning him to his normal
mutant form because Peters time as one
of the Phoenix five as well as the
avatar sit Arak made him immensely
powerful with a need to destroy for the
most part his actions saw the deaths of
countless humans in the name of creating
a better world looking to Ileana as a
comfort instead of coming to his aid she
revealed that when she offered to become
siddur axe avatar she had known colossus
would take her place instead now where
the goal of this was to go to Peter into
becoming as angry as possible the other
half of this reason was revealed when
Ileana transported Colossus to Limbo net
aside chat for a second as a mutant with
the ability to travel through dimensions
and time Ileana rose to prominence in
Marvel Comics during the inferno
storyline in 1988 well the story saw her
giving in to the demon forces of limbo
embracing her darker self and opening a
portal to Manhattan following his
conclusion Ileana became a sort of ruler
of limbo and that whatever she was there
she could manipulate the very fabric of
that dimension achieving any effect she
desired but because the experience left
her scarred her Colossus always viewed
her as an innocent child
allowing him to experience what it was
like to be possessed by another entity
fall from grace and become a demon
himself went towards helping Colossus to
understand that Ileana was not an
innocent child anymore and that the
events of Inferno had scarred her for
life
to this end with the two engaging in
battle with one another Ilyana was able
to cast off the powers of CID Iraq
returning Colossus to his normal mutant
form but not without a betrayal of his
trust
leaving the brother and sister isolated
from one another going into the events
of secret wars leading into all-new
all-different marvel with that being
said we're gonna bring this video to an
end and make sure you guys post a
comment down below and let me know what
character or concept you think we should
talk about for next week's video on
coming book concepts and I will catch
you guys later please